- I recently posted five individual videos
on how to communicate
clearly and confidently.
What I've done in this video
is to stitch those all together
so you can go through the whole series,
step-by-step, in one organized place.
Here we go.
(upbeat rock music)
The point of this video, part one,
is that if you want to speak more clearly
and confidently, then use plain language.
Why is that? Because plain
language is clear language.
You'll be at your most confident
when you know what you're saying.
Tip one, don't use fancy vocabulary words
for their own sake.
A lot of people don't like
this tip, but it works.
I'll give you some examples in a minute,
but I wanted to first address
why we sometimes use fancy words
when they don't add value.
One reason people use fancy
words is they mistakenly believe
it'll make them sound smart.
In other words, they are
trying to impress others
with a big vocabulary.
They might not state that goal aloud.
They might not even realize
that it's their goal,
but it is a common go-to mindset
that's just below the surface
and it motivates many of us.
And when we talk to impress others,
we tend to use fancier
words than necessary.
We stretch to the outer
limits of our vocabulary,
but we may find that those fancy words
don't exactly mean what
we think they mean.
For example, instead of
saying a straightforward word
like think, we might be tempted
to say "contemplate."
Instead of work, we say
things like, "exert oneself."
Instead of problem, we
say "problematical."
And if you think I'm exaggerating,
I've heard numerous people
use the word problematical
for no reason whatsoever.
I saw a meme on social media
of what looked like a wise
old man and the caption read,
"Sometimes I use words I don't understand
so I can sound more photosynthesis."
We do this when we
speak and when we write.
A while back, I was
grading a student's paper.
She used a fancy word
that didn't belong there,
and I gave her the benefit of the doubt,
and I asked her when I
handed the paper back
what she meant by that sentence,
and I pointed at the misplaced fancy word,
and she literally said,
"Oh, I don't know what that means,
I just thought it sounded good."
Many people do this when they speak
and when they write, they
essentially play with a thesaurus
or play with a thesaurus in their head,
take it too far, and the
word they end up using
is too distant from a meaning
that makes sense anymore.
Another reason people
may use fancier words
than they need to is for camouflage.
I'm convinced that some speakers
may not really understand
exactly what they're saying just yet.
There is an expression that people credit
to Richard Feynman, a physicist,
and this is a paraphrase
of what he originally said,
but he deserves the credit
for the idea itself.
"If you can't give a freshman-level
lecture on a subject,
then you don't really understand it yet."
He said this about himself,
and I think he's right.
The people who really know their stuff
are able to explain ideas
to a beginner without
oversimplifying a subject
or losing the heart of the matter.
They're able to use everyday language
to explain even the most complex subjects.
I believe people also use
big words as camouflage
because somewhere inside
themselves they may realize
that what they're saying
isn't that meaningful
or important, so they use bigger words
to make the idea sound more profound
or to cover over a piece of their thinking
that is not crystal clear just yet.
The lesson is this:
Don't be tempted to use
fancy-sounding vocabulary words
because you think it'll sound smart
or as a form of camouflage.
It's likely that somebody listening,
who you're speaking with,
will know what the word means
and maybe ask a follow-up
question and then you'll be stuck.
Tip number two is really
the solution to number one;
use the plain English version
of words whenever possible.
Do what I call the reverse
thesaurus exercise.
Look for more straightforward ways
to communicate your message.
My advice is to use this simple
and clear word as often as possible.
Let's flip those earlier
examples and look at it again.
Instead of contemplate, exert
oneself, or problematical,
use words like, think, work and problem.
Everybody understands those words
and 90% of the time the fancier versions
of those words usually
add no additional meaning
or information to the sentence.
So here's a question: do these words
sound too basic for you?
Well, let's put it to the test
when you are the listener,
we'll look at a classic
example of a famous quotation.
In the first version, I'll use
fancier words than necessary.
You may still recognize the idea,
but I think you'll agree
it does not sound as good
as the original.
"Refrain from requesting
what the government can
provide for its citizens.
Comparatively, request
what the populace can offer
the nation-state."
Does that concept sound a bit familiar?
Well, let's hear the original.
"Ask not what your country can do for you.
Ask what you can do for your country."
I'm sure you recognize
the famous quotation
from John F. Kennedy from his speech.
Now, let's put these two side by side
and look at the way Kennedy
used plain language.
You'll notice that Kennedy uses
almost entirely single-syllable words.
The only two-syllable word
in the entire quotation
is the word country,
and that's a word that
cannot be substituted
for a single syllable word
and still makes sense.
This plain language also allowed JFK
to add emphasis and say
it like he meant it.
When your words are clear like this
and you know that everybody
will understand you,
you can lean in and communicate
the idea with confidence.
If you look at my
dressed-up version again,
you can see that the fancier
words rarely add value,
meaning, or additional important
information to the message.
The fancier words usually
weaken the overall impact
of your message.
And keep in mind, JFK was
known for his intelligence.
He had a powerful vocabulary
when he needed it.
The legend is he was a speed-reader
and that he read every single
major newspaper each day
by the time he finished breakfast,
but when he spoke, he wanted
everybody to understand him.
He didn't feel the need to
be perceived as intelligent
because he knew who he was.
His focus was on being clear
so that everybody who
heard him understood him,
and that should be your goal as well.
Now, you might be saying,
hold on a minute, Alex.
Sometimes we can't do that.
Sometimes there are words
that we must use to say
what needs to be said, and that's true.
There are sometimes technical
words that we have to use,
otherwise we can't say
what we need to say,
and that's totally understandable.
The tip is to keep the
rest of your sentence
simple and clear so that
the irreplaceable words
don't get lost in a sea
of other demanding words.
By the way, if you like
what you're hearing,
I encourage you to find
out more about my classes
and group coaching options
and my communication coach academy.
You may want to take a
look at our free class
and handout on the top five
essential communication skills
that all professionals should have.
I'll put a link to those resources
in the description below this video.
Tip three: avoid using industry jargon,
abbreviations, or acronyms.
For example, instead of
using the abbreviation "SME,"
or S-M-E, just say
"subject matter expert."
Instead of saying ROI, say,
"return on investment."
Now let's see if you know this one:
Instead of POV, what
would you say instead?
If you said "proof of
value," you're correct.
However, if you said "point of view,"
you may also be correct
because acronyms are confusing.
The speaker may intend one meaning,
but the listener may
assume a different meaning.
The research I've seen shows
that abbreviations, jargon
and acronyms create misunderstandings.
That's the opposite of
clear and confident.
I witnessed this firsthand a few years ago
when I was working with a
client on an offsite retreat.
As part of the weekend,
we had 40 individuals
who were all part of the same division
in a large international company.
These 40 people understood
each other's worlds
better than anyone else,
but when one of the
speakers went up to present
and filled his presentation
with technical terms,
jargon and acronyms, by the end,
almost nobody had any idea
what he was talking about anymore.
His close colleagues were
literally looking at each other
and shrugging their shoulders
and whispering, "I have
no idea what he's saying."
And here's why; anytime
someone uses an acronym,
abbreviation or jargon, the listener has
to slow down their thinking a little bit,
translate what it might mean,
and during those moments of translation,
the speaker has already
moved on in the conversation
and the listener
experiences missing moments
of understanding a gap.
Using jargon and acronyms like this
creates a series of gaps
in your listeners' minds
and they're missing pieces of your ideas.
These add up and listeners
won't be able to follow
what you're saying as well by the end.
That's gonna hurt your
credibility as a speaker
and as a professional.
So instead of using these shortcuts,
just say the words out loud,
define what you mean.
If they're important terms,
so that everybody understands
and follows your meaning.
Here's a summary of the
tips in this lesson.
Don't use fancy vocabulary words
for their own sake or
try to impress others.
Instead, use plain
English versions of words
whenever possible.
In the same way, avoid
using industry jargon,
abbreviations or acronyms.
Plain language is clear language.
You'll sound more confident
when you speak this way.
As I mentioned, I encourage you
to find out more about the free resources
on the website that you
can take advantage of
and that class on the top five essential
communication skills that all
professionals should have.
This is a five-part series
on how to speak clearly and confidently,
tune in next time when you learn about how
to use concise sentences
to their maximum advantage.
I look forward to reading
your comments below
about what you thought of
this video and the tips in it.
Until next time, thanks, God
bless, and I will see you soon.
(upbeat rock music)
You're going to learn how to speak clearly
and confidently using the
power of concise sentences.
As one of my consultant
friend always says,
Concise sounds confident.
This is part two in a five-part series
on speaking clearly and confidently.
Here are my three interrelated tips
on how to use concise sentences
that'll make you sound fantastic.
One; Avoid long, demanding sentences.
When I coach corporate clients,
one of the most common
communication issues I see
is that they speak in
really long sentences.
Essentially, they string two
or three sentences together
into one long, redundant super sentence.
That's too demanding for listeners.
This could be the case for
regular updates at meetings
or certainly public speaking situations.
I can personally relate to the tendency
to want to tell listeners
everything you know all at once.
You might have a lot on your mind
and this might be your one
opportunity to share it.
But long sentences make it more difficult
for your listeners to understand you.
It's just like as if you're reading
and you come across a sentence in a book
that goes for five or six lines long
or a paragraph that stretches
over two or more pages.
That can overwhelm readers
and in the same way
listeners need a break.
If listeners cannot follow you
because you're long-winded,
you won't create the impression
that you are clear and confident.
That will wear your listeners out,
but the question is, how
can you avoid long sentences
when there's so much to say?
My advice is to keep those long sentences,
but find a way to break
them in a natural spot
into two or three shorter sentences.
Now, this is the right advice,
but it's easier said than done.
Many clients are used to
speaking in long sentences
and they usually struggle at first
to get into the rhythm
of shorter sentences.
So let's talk about tip number two;
practice speaking in bullet points.
Now, speaking as if you're
stating bullet points
feels stiff and wooden at first,
but trust this exercise,
it's just practice.
If you train yourself to sound this way,
you'll be more clear and
confident in actual meetings
and in real conversations.
I learned the technique
I'm about to show you
from actual clients that I've worked with.
I've noticed that my clients
who spoke the most clearly
and sounded the most confident
spoke in short sentences.
To me, it sounded like they
were speaking in bullet points,
almost as if they had a PowerPoint slide
to refer to, and they sounded fantastic.
Here's how they do it.
They make one short
statement after another,
but each one is followed by a brief pause
where the period goes on the slide.
They don't say "um," or "uh,"
between the ideas,
they just pause silently at
the end of each sentence.
They also don't connect their sentences
with words like "and," or "so."
Be on the lookout for those fill-in words.
The top two words that
create run-on sentences
are "And," and "So."
My clear and confident
clients don't use them.
When they reach a period
at the end of a thought,
they just pause silently
for about a second.
The rhythm goes like this:
Short sentence, pause;
short sentence, pause;
short sentence, pause.
As if they're working their way
through bullet points on a slide.
So let me demonstrate a
before and after example.
I'll read one long
connected sentence first
and then I'll fix it.
Here's the long demanding version.
"I have several steps to
accomplish by the end of the day
and I have to outline their proposal
and run that by the copy editor
and then get the final version approved,
so I'd likely then add some images
and illustrations to bring it to life
so it looks professional and polished
instead of looking like a
rough outline of ideas."
That's clearly a demanding
sentence for listeners.
That's line after line with no break.
Now let's fix it.
Here's what it sounds like
when I pretend I'm
speaking in bullet points
with tiny pauses in between.
"I have several steps to accomplish.
By the end of the day I have
to outline the proposal.
I'll run that by the copy editor.
I'll then get the final version approved.
I'll likely add some images
and illustrations to bring it to life.
We want this to look
professional and polished
instead of looking like
a rough outline of ideas.
Now, neither version is Shakespeare.
I'll grant you that, but
to make it sound better,
all I did was turn that one long sentence
into six shorter sentences.
The exact same information
is in both versions.
Now, if you wanted to, you can rewind
and practice both versions
to hear the difference
and feel the cadence or
the rhythm for yourself.
For your own communication,
break those long sentences into two
or perhaps three sentences.
Pretend you're working your way
through bullet points on a slide.
And the more you practice this,
the more clear and confident you'll sound.
I was going over this tip
with a client in my Communication
Coach Academy recently.
He asked how I would translate this tip
for one-on-one or group conversations,
and here's what I told them.
Use concise sentences
and conversations by,
tip number three:
Using short talking turns.
Conversations should be a
dialogue, not a monologue.
When it's your turn to
talk in a conversation,
keep it short, boil down
what you want to say
to a sentence or two.
When you speak in short
sentences in one-on-one
or group situations, you'll
absolutely sound clearer
and more confident
because you're speaking in
clear bite-sized chunks.
Some people resist this advice
because they wanna make sure
that once it's their talking turn,
they say everything they came to say,
and I totally understand that.
But I have found the opposite to be true.
When they use long talking turns,
they're more likely to get
interrupted with questions.
It's unlikely that most
other professionals
want to hear all your thoughts
on all your topics on your list that day.
They want to have a back
and forth conversation.
It's 100% natural for them
to want to respond to
each idea in real time.
When we're using short talking turns,
the conversation's much more
satisfying and effective.
All of the same good
information will come out.
It just may come out in
smaller digestible bites
as you go back and forth.
This is all the more important
when you're speaking with people above you
in the organization or
people with high status,
they want you to get to the point quickly.
If you have a high stakes conversation
on your calendar like this,
then prepare yourself ahead of time
to take short talking turns
and make sure it's a dialogue.
Don't attempt to monologue
with a long talking turn
with high status people in business.
They want you to lead with a bottom line
and then you can both talk about it.
In summary, concise sounds confident.
Here's a recap of how to
use concise sentences:
Avoid long demanding sentences,
practice speaking in bullet points
and use short talking turns.
If you're benefiting from
this series of videos,
I encourage you to find
out more about my classes
and group coaching at my
Communication Coach Academy.
There's also a full page
of free resources including a free class
on the top five essential
communication skills
that all professionals should have.
I'll put links to those in the
description below the video.
Be sure to take a look at part three
in this five-part series
on how to speak clearly
and confidently by using
identifiable talking points.
I'll show you how to do
that in the next video.
Until then, thanks, God
bless, and I'll see you soon.
(upbeat rock music)
You're going to learn how to speak clearly
and confidently by designing your message
with logical main points.
If you're following along,
this is part three in a five-part series
on speaking clearly and confidently.
Here's the bottom line for this video.
Clear and confident speakers communicate
in logical main points or talking points.
In other words, they communicate
in an orderly fashion.
For these tips, I'm going to assume
you're in a professional situation,
like a team meeting.
You could use these tips
to prepare a message
or as part of a Q&A in a group situation,
so picture yourself talking
in a group for these tips.
Tip one, the easiest way
to add a sense of logic
and structure to your message
is to give a brief preview,
and then number your main points allowed.
For example, you might say you wanted
to talk about three important steps.
First, let's look for
a way to boost revenue.
Second, we'll explore how to cut costs,
and third, we must reach new customers.
My previous statement
there was simply to say,
I want to talk about
three important steps.
Listeners now know that
you have three points
and then you'd number your points
as you say them.
When you say first, second, and third,
these are called signposts.
You're numbering your
points to make it easier
for your listeners to hear the logic
and structure of your message.
That adds a lot of clarity
to what you've said.
But you'll notice
that it also makes you
sound incredibly confident
in what you're saying.
You sound like you've thought about this
and you know what you're talking about.
In contrast, if you don't
literally say first, second,
and third, when you get to those points,
your listeners won't
hear that extra clarity.
It could sound to them
like you're just listening random items,
but by adding those signposts,
first, second, third,
you sound more prepared and credible.
I'll do another example,
and on this first version,
I won't use a preview or a signpost.
And then I'll redo it
by adding those elements
and you tell me which one
sounds more clear and confident.
Picture yourself saying each
of these in a group meeting.
Here's the first example.
"Let's identify other
departments we could work with.
We'll meet with them to discuss our idea
and we can collaborate
to draft a proposal."
Now, there's nothing wrong with that.
It's already clear as it is,
but listen to the difference
when I say it with a
preview and signposts.
"I see three next steps for this project.
First, let's identify other
departments we could work with.
Second, we'll meet with
them to discuss our idea
and third, we can collaborate
to draft a proposal."
Both of these are passable messages,
but most people would agree
that the second example
has that extra edge
that makes it sound more like leadership.
Adding a preview and signposts
makes the message sound official.
As The Rock used to say,
if you're picking up what I'm
throwing down in this series,
I encourage you to find out more
about my Communication Coach Academy.
We have over 20 classes
and we offer live group
coaching on top of that.
There's also a page full
of entirely free resources
and a free class
on the top five essential
communication skills
for professionals.
I'll put links to that and other resources
in the description below the video.
Tip number two, if you
have a persuasive message,
use the problem, solution,
benefits main points.
In professional situations,
we are often asking our
colleagues, supervisors,
or clients for something
at the end of our message.
We call this an ask, a
call to action, or a CTA.
Every couple of weeks we're asking
for funding, support
or collaborative help.
When we do, we must build a case
and persuade people to join our cause.
When you're sharing that
type of message, the best way
to organize your main points is
in problem-solution benefit order.
It works the same
as the first, second, third
signpost we talked about,
except instead of filling in
first, second, and third points
with whatever topics you're talking about,
you're gonna fill them in
with the problem you're
there to talk about
or the need, the solution, or your plan,
and the benefits.
It must be in that order
to be an effective persuasive message.
Here's an example of a message
about asking your supervisor
or team to hire an additional person
for an important upcoming project.
First, as you know, our key issue
is that we lost a couple
of people last quarter
and we're heading into our
next project shorthanded.
Second, because of this,
I recommend we hire
at least one additional
person who can help us
with the instructional design
aspects of our project.
Third, the upside of this
is it will free up the rest of us
to increase the quality of our work
because we're not trying
to pull double duty.
A couple of pointers on this message.
You could use the actual keywords;
problem, solution, and benefit
to express your message,
or you can substitute words
that mean almost the
same thing like I did.
For example, I use the word
issue, recommend, and upside;
instead of problem, solution, benefit.
There are a few ways
to communicate the same logical structure.
If you want to say issues,
obstacles, trouble or hangups,
instead of using the
actual word "problem,"
that's up to you.
If you want to use words like plan,
recommendation or suggestion
rather than the word, "solution,"
those are great substitutes.
You can use whatever words
fit your message best.
Just be sure you're
structuring your message
around a foundation of
problem, solution, benefits;
in that order, and you use
some unmistakable keywords
to signal those three points.
I'd also like to point out here
that I use signposts for
each of those points.
I said first, second, and third.
In addition to saying
issue, recommend and upside.
I almost always recommend using signposts.
When in doubt, use signposts.
They usually help and they never hurt,
but in some cases using a
signpost is not necessary
if your keywords are crystal clear.
Tip number three is a variation
on a persuasive message design.
For some messages, three points structured
around problem, cause,
solution may be a better fit
for your message than
problem, solution, benefit.
And there are really no ways to tell
ahead of time which design is best
in your particular situation
for your message and your audience.
That choice is up to you.
But in my experience
working with my clients,
I find that problem,
cause, solution main points
tend to work really well
with an internal audience;
like your team or perhaps your supervisor.
Most of my clients agree
that problem, solution,
benefits main points
work equally well with
either an internal audience
like those people that I just mentioned
or an external audience,
like a potential client.
Here's an example of what problem
cause solution main points
sound like for a brief message.
And for the sake of variety,
I will not use signposts in this example
so you can see how it sounds
just with the key words.
Our biggest problem currently
is that we have been losing more clients
because of attrition
than we thought we would.
The cause of this has been the lack
of a coherent onboarding
and orientation process
for new clients.
The solution I recommend
is to create a new onboarding process
that includes a balance of
face-to-face interaction
and email follow-up and equal measure.
Some people I've worked with
are hesitant to use keywords
that are as deliberate as
problem, cause, solution.
Like before, you can substitute other
keywords and phrases for these.
Just make sure your keywords stand out
and are unmistakable
so your listeners know
exactly what point you're on.
There are other ways
to design your message
around logical points, but
these are the top three ways
that you've probably already heard
in most professional settings.
If you can learn to speak like this
and make it a habit, you'll
sound 10 times more clear
and confident for every
important message you share.
I quoted The Rock earlier and
I'm gonna quote him again.
If you smell what I'm
cooking in this series
and wanna find out more
about my Communication coach Academy,
then take a look at all the links
and the expandable
description below this video.
There are free resources
there as always on the site.
And I look forward to hearing your point
of view on this video in
that comment section below.
Until next time, thanks, God
bless and I'll see you soon.
(upbeat rock music)
Today you're gonna learn
how to speak clearly
and confidently and I'll
show you a specific method
that you can use
to back up everything
you say with evidence.
This is part four in a five part series
on how to speak clearly and confidently.
I'll put links to the entire series
below once all five parts are posted.
Let's now learn to use
the PREP talking points.
PREP is an acronym which you
probably know I don't like,
so let me quickly explain this.
When you have something important to say,
do it in this order.
State your point of view.
Next, give a reason for your point of view
and then you give a concrete example
or other evidence that
illustrates your point of view.
When you add even a little
bit of evidence like this,
you'll sound much more
confident and persuasive.
And then you restate your
point of view at the end
to show that you've
finished your talking turn.
I consider the second P in
the PREP method optional,
depending upon the situation
and the length of your message.
We'll talk through some
examples in a moment,
but first, the PREP method
and talking points comes from the world
of impromptu speaking.
In the real world, the
PREP points are useful
for any kind of group meeting situation,
high stakes conversation
or during a Q&A session
where you have two simultaneous goals.
First, you wanna sound clear
and concise and confident,
but second, you also wanna make sure
you support what you say with evidence
and stay on track while you do it.
You can use this for a
message that's as short
as three sentences or
let's say 15 to 20 seconds,
or you can develop it a bit
into a 30 to 45 second message.
Let's walk through this.
Here are the first two
examples of how I would sound
in an everyday conversation.
For these first two examples,
we'll do the short version
of about 15 seconds or so
and I'll leave off the
optional P at the end
because it's really not necessary
for a message this short.
Here's my first example:
Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around
and I think we should get on board.
One reason for its popularity
is that anybody at any
skill level can play.
For example, I have a
friend who is 80 years old
and plays couples with her husband,
but when her grandchildren
visit, they all play together.
Here's another example of
what that would sound like
in a professional situation.
We'll pretend we're in a
group meeting with your team
and we're talking about
what vendor your team
should work with moving forward.
It's now your turn to voice your opinion
and you're going to use the PRE points.
For example, you could say,
"I recommend we hire vendor A
because we already know
they do quality work
and they're easy to work with.
Our last project with them, for example,
came in under budget and a
month ahead of schedule."
In mere seconds, you
can use the PREP method
to express yourself
clearly and confidently
and back up what you say
with a concrete example.
Let's do some additional fine-tuning
so we can really
understand each point here
and that will also help us expand this
to a 30 or 45-second message.
The first P is pretty straightforward.
This is where you express
your point of view,
position, or opinion about a subject.
This is your bottom line.
In school, you might call
this your thesis statement.
My tip for the P is that
this is what you would say
if you were only allowed to say
what you thought in one concise sentence.
Next, the R stands for reason.
This is where you will
give a clear explanation
of why you have that point
of view in the first place.
This answers a question
listeners will usually ask themselves
before they realize it.
They might be thinking for example,
well, why do you believe that?
To make it bulletproof,
the way I coach my clients
is to literally use words like because,
or start with the phrase,
"The reason is..."
The reason is when you start
with those lead-in keywords,
you will usually be able to
find the rest of the words
to offer a clear reason
for your point of view.
That's exactly what I did
for my previous examples.
When I talked about the
popularity of pickleball,
I used the lead in phrase, "One reason."
For the professional example,
I said I wanted to do
business with vendor A
and I signaled that I was giving a reason
by using the keyword "Because."
So my tip for the R, the reason,
is that if you're not sure how to explain
why you have that point
of view, use keywords
like reason or because as
you draft your message,
and that will usually help you state
your reason more clearly.
With that in mind, let's talk about
how to turn this into a
30 to 45-second message.
For a slightly longer message like this,
the first two steps, the P and
the R stay exactly the same.
You should still express your
point of view in one sentence
and give your reasons in one
or perhaps two very concise sentences.
But as mentioned, the E stands
for example or evidence.
In my earlier illustrations,
my examples were quite short,
but a longer message usually means
providing additional examples or evidence.
The E is really the only talking point
in prep that you can expand
without repeating yourself.
And to transition to your examples,
just use the lead-in
phrase, "For example,"
and then immediately
share your illustration
or other evidence.
For pickleball, I could have
added additional examples
to make this into a longer message.
I originally gave examples about
how my 80-year-old friend plays
and they also play with
their grandchildren,
but let's say I was sharing this message
with my local parks and
recreation department and leaders,
and I wanted to convince them
to add some pickleball courts
to our community center.
For that audience, I would
add some other evidence
in the form of statistics
and other information.
I would've shared
that the association for
pickleball professionals
shows that over 36 million
Americans now play the sport.
It's now more popular than tennis.
I would've mentioned that the cost
of pickleball is less than half
of what it costs to play tennis.
I would've mentioned
that three nearby towns
now have dedicated pickleball
courts and leagues.
You'll notice that each
additional piece of information
and evidence is unique and
that's really important.
Make sure each example
adds new information
so that you don't simply repeat yourself
and get long-winded.
I could do the same thing
with my example about hiring vendor A.
I would add additional examples
and evidence that back up my message
without repeating myself,
so to expand a prep message
to between 30 and 45 seconds,
the only point you expand on is the E
by adding more examples and evidence.
The other talking points
stay exactly the same,
but now because your
message is a bit longer,
this justifies adding
the second P to the end.
This is where you restate
your point of view.
The second P, if you think about it,
functions as a one-sentence
mini conclusion
for your message.
You might reword the second
P a little differently
than the first, but it must reiterate
your original point of view
to show that you're finished talking.
I would say, "And that's why I believe
we should get on board with pickleball.
Or, "To me, vendor A is the right choice."
To summarize, use the PRE points
if you have a brief message to share
and want to support that with evidence.
And use the entire prep
method with the second P,
if you have a slightly longer message
and want to support everything you say
with additional examples
and more evidence.
Both are extremely tight
ways to make a point
and you now know how to
express yourself clearly
and confidently and back
up everything you say
without getting long-winded.
I encourage you to take
a look at my website
at all the free resources we have there,
like the class on the top
five communication skills
that every professional should have.
I'll put links to that below
and to my Communication Coach Academy,
so you can take a look at
that while you're there.
We have classes and other
group coaching options as well,
and stick around for the fifth
and final part of this series
and that next video we'll
talk about how you can speak
with more conviction
in everything you say.
Till next time, thanks, God
bless, and I will see you soon.
(upbeat rock music)
You're going to learn some tips
to speak clearly and confidently.
Specifically, you'll learn how to speak
with more conviction.
This is part five in a five part series
on how to speak clearly and confidently.
This is the last video
and it's 100% compatible
with every other lesson
and tip in the series.
If you've been watching the series
and still haven't subscribed yet,
then you can do that right now.
And if you're finding
these lessons helpful,
then feel free to check out my
Communication Coach Academy.
We have loads of free resources there,
group coaching options
and a variety of classes
and communication, public
speaking and leadership.
Today's video is all about
speaking with conviction
and the bottom line is if
you have something to say,
say it like you mean it.
Tip number one to speak
with more conviction
is to increase your volume.
I would say that more than
half of the clients I work with
do not speak loudly
enough in group situations
or during presentations.
The trouble is people who speak softly
generally do not sound confident
in what they're saying.
If you speak at a below average volume,
it's going to create a
below average impression.
In contrast, if you can
increase your volume
by just 10 or 20%, everything you say
will sound more
enthusiastic and committed.
If you're in a one-on-one
conversation, of course,
you have to keep the level
of volume conversational,
but in front of a group
of almost any size,
increase your volume by about 10 or 20%.
For public speaking,
the tip is to let your
voice fill the room.
The larger the room and the
more people that are there,
the more volume you use.
When you speak a little louder,
it'll make everything you say
like you're speaking with conviction.
When I work with clients,
we'll often do this
in workshops with somebody
who is speaking too softly for the room.
They volunteer and we put them up there
in front of everybody.
We're really supportive
and we gradually get them to speak louder.
And you can try this with me right now
and I'm going to use a sample sentence
about pickleball from a
previous lesson in this series.
We'll gradually increase the volume
and it's just about pickleball,
but you'll see how this
makes a difference.
Repeat the sentence after me
in your normal speaking volume.
"Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around."
Now, let's say that again,
and this time, let's speak 10% louder
and let your voice start to
fill whatever room you're in.
"Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around."
Now let's increase the
volume one more time
to 20% higher than your normal volume.
And say it again with me.
"Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around."
Now, I'm not there with you,
but I'm willing to speculate
that when you speak a little louder,
you'll sound more confident
and convinced about what you just said.
You may also notice as you
practice speaking louder,
that you're benefiting
from a few other positive side effects.
I've noticed that when most
of my clients increase their volume,
they also increase their vocal variety
in the sound of their voice,
so they no longer sound monotone.
That's because increasing your volume
naturally improves your
tone and inflection.
My clients also usually start
to become more animated in terms
of their gestures in their body language
and their facial expressions.
I can't obviously see you right now,
but let me ask,
did you notice that
your facial expressions
became more animated when
you increased your volume?
Did you gesture with your
hands without realizing it?
All of that will make you come across
as more confident in what you're saying.
So all you have to do
is increase your volume
by about 10% or 20%
and you'll look and sound
like you're speaking
with more conviction.
Tip number two, so speak
with more conviction,
is to emphasize the most
important words in each sentence.
In fact, I just did that
in my previous sentence,
so I'll do it again
and you tell me which words I emphasized.
"To speak with more conviction.
Emphasize the most important
words in each sentence."
Did you hear it? And you can do the same.
All I did was slow down
and lean into what I considered
to be the most important words,
and you should do that
in every single sentence.
Just pick whatever two or three words
in a row matter the most in each sentence.
Slow down and add emphasis to them.
There are lots of reasons
to emphasize keywords.
The first is that when
people speak too rapidly
and rush through every thought
and every sentence, it
doesn't sound confident.
It sounds like they're just
trying to get through a message
and their main goal is
to get it over with.
Now, rushing through may
help you accomplish the goal
of finishing as fast as possible,
but it's not going to make you sound
like you believe what you're saying.
Another reason people rush is
because of anxiety and nerves.
But whatever reason you have
for speaking too quickly,
emphasizing the most important words
in each and every sentence
will give you a much more
confident-sounding rhythm.
It also helps your listeners
because now they know
that if it's important
to you as a speaker, then you're signaling
that it should be important to them.
And here's another tip within a tip.
When you get to the end
of your talking turn,
make sure you use the
same type of emphasis
on the last three words you say.
And make sure your voice
goes down at the end
toward the period punctuation mark.
It should sound like you
are landing the plane
on your talking turn.
Let's use our pickleball example again
and say it along with me.
We'll pretend that this is
the end of our talking turn.
Emphasize the last three words
as you read this and notice
how certain you sound.
"Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around."
You really wanna lean into
those last three words.
Make sure it sounds like
you're making a statement
and not asking a question.
Third, let's talk about eye contact
and how you can use this to come across
as more confident,
like you really believe
what you just said.
Before I give you this tip,
let me explain how I learned this myself.
I've been going to group meetings
as a participant and coaching
clients for decades now.
And I've noticed a very subtle behavior
that differentiates the
most confident speakers
from everybody else in the room.
First and most obviously,
confident speakers
tend to make direct eye contact
with people as they're speaking.
That's probably not too surprising,
and I would guess, like most people,
you make at least some direct eye contact
when you're speaking, but if you don't,
make sure you practice eye contact
while you're speaking
and sharing your message.
A second: Here's the
subtle difference I noticed
about eye contact.
When the most confident speakers
finish their talking turns,
they keep their eyes and their chin up
and they continue to make eye contact
with the next person in
the group who speaks.
They don't stare or
glare at the next person
in a confrontational way.
They simply maintain eye contact
with whoever speaks next.
In contrast, professionals
who seem to lack confidence
in what they said, finish
their talking turn,
and then they drop their eyes
and their chin toward the
table, toward their notes
or toward a device.
And when they break eye contact like that
and look down after they speak,
it creates the impression
that they don't believe in
or stand behind what they just said.
To reiterate the tip, when
you finish your talking turn
in a group situation, keep your chin up,
maintain eye contact
with whoever speaks next,
and it will cast a very positive light
on what you just said,
and it'll come across like
you stand behind your message.
If you watched all five
videos in this series
on how to speak clearly and confidently,
please let me know in a comment.
I would love to celebrate that
with you with my own comment,
and I will give you a heart.
And don't forget to take
a look at my website.
There's free resources
there that I mentioned,
group coaching options and classes.
Thank you for joining me in this journey.
Until next time, thanks, God
bless, and I will see you soon.